hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out these brand new headphones
by Dolby these are the Dolby dimension
headphones these feature a few new
things that are really excited to test
out most of which there's this thing
called life mix you can put the
headphones on and you can decide how
much of the outside noise you want to
hear and how much of your content you
want to hear that's gonna be really fun
because my sister and I do edit a lot
side by side she'll be editing a video I
don't want to actually hear her video
but she wants to be able to hear me
talking to her and vice versa I'm also
excited about the cinematic sound when
you move your head you'll be able to
hear the change in whatever it is that
you're watching so it's really like you
are so immersed that you're actually
there a huge thank you to BB for
partnering with me on this video when
they reached out about these headphones
I was so excited because I'm such a huge
fan of Dolby when you hear the name
Dolby you automatically know that it's
going to be something that is incredible
because they've been around for so long
and it's one of those names that you
just trust so I just knew that this is
something that I had to try out look at
these they're on like a little pillow
these headphones look so comfortable
makes me want to take a nap it's a nice
weight a really really nice feel they
fit me perfectly I didn't even have to
adjust anything am i yelling I might be
yelling anytime I put headphones on it
automatically start yelling because I
can't really hear myself it's got the
little L and the R inside there these
are so comfortable it has like a nice
padding up at the top and this is like a
perfect fit over top of your ears
sometimes I feel like these types of
headphones can be a little bit
overpowering but they sit just perfectly
they're extremely comfortable I wish
that I could put these on your little
head let's try them
[Music]
how does that feel I wish that you could
experience it that's the hardest part
when I'm making videos is how do I
accurately describe what I'm feeling and
I try really hard I'm sometimes not good
at describing my feelings but I'm
feeling pretty excited about these let's
see what else is inside here I think
that Dolby should also consider making
bed sheets because this is something
that I would like to take a nap in you
guys get in there well that is so soft
so the thing that's really cool about
these is you can pair three separate
devices to it at the same time and you
can switch between them so a lot of
times I'll be on my phone I'll be on my
iMac and I'll be on my laptop especially
when I'm traveling I would like to
switch between my music or my editing
and really it's just great to be able to
have this one press of a button to
switch between all the things that are
connected this also acts as touch
controls so if you tap twice you can
toggle between life mix and active noise
cancellation and there's an accompanying
app that goes with this so you're able
to control just how that mix sounds and
you can control your headphones so there
is virtualization and head tracking this
is where you can pair each one of your
devices that corresponds to each of the
buttons that you have on the headset so
if I want to connect to my phone it's
the first one and when I connect my
laptop and iMac it would be the next two
so I guess now that I have this set up I
need to play something let's listen to
the new imagine dragons album I wish so
you could experience this okay I want to
check out the light mix so to do that I
got a track play hello oh my god this is
so weird what is that whoa oh my god
this is so silly
I do tend to overreact a lot but this is
unlike anything that I feel like I've
really experienced in headphones before
so when I double tap right now I can't
hear myself even talking all I hear is
the music I double tap that activates
the life mix so it's like microphones
are now picking up what is around me
like I can hear myself inside of my head
playing while my music is playing that's
the only way that I can explain it this
is so wild so if you've ever had
headphones on while you're recording
something the only way that I can kind
of
it is you put the headphones on you can
also monitor yourself talking it's
picking up my voice oh my gosh I can't
wait to try this okay I can't wait to
get Jenna's reaction she has no idea
like I read about what this feature was
this is not there's also a little
charging dock I'm gonna try to give you
guys an audio example of what I'm
hearing picture right now that you have
the headphones on and this is what it
sounds like if I was talking to you
right now with
this is what it sounds like so it's kind
of like everything is that a perfect mix
my voice is recorded into the song so
everything is just it's called life mix
for a reason what I need to go watch
some content I need to connect the rest
of my devices there's so many things
that I want to do now I need a moment
Jenna dude these are so freaking cool
and you're gonna see you're gonna see
soon you're gonna see so so soon I'm
trying to film my video but we've got a
little doggy so you guys can see there's
three different little sections right
here excuse me I'm so sorry
okay so the three buttons those
correspond what whatever it is it's
connected so as you can see right there
the first one is lit up and that is the
iPhone so now I'm gonna connect my
MacBook if I'm allowed stops connect the
MacBook he's trying to nudge my computer
off okay so Dobie dimensions are gonna
connect there we go
the MacBook is now connected now that
the MacBook is connected I've the
virtualization and the head tracking on
so what this means is I'm going to be so
fully immersed in my film I've
downloaded ready player one so let's hit
play no freaking way so when I tilt my
head its surrounding me okay now watch
this would you say you're yelling okay
this has built-in microphones so it's
picking up the sound around me and
completely mixing in what I talk to me
what do you want for dinner no way oh ma
I love dinner okay wait so I can turn it
down with the touch controls I can turn
it up so the cool thing about that is
what I'm doing this it's turning down my
movie and I can say something dinner I
can hear you you're saying dinner and
when I double tap and turn it back up
I'm back in my movie
this is so cool you have to try this you
you have to look I can't even explain it
Jen you got to try it okay you gotta get
over here it's so hard to explain to
them what I'm experiencing so I'm gonna
try to make you experience it okay we're
gonna put these on I could do it oh oh
look at them on your ears okay I know I
was a lot I just watched you do it he
turned up a little oh okay now double
tap on it
hello can you hear me
did you hear me it's like you're in my
head I know I'm in my own head I know
but now imagine dragons is also in my
head it's like a perfect mix so you can
still hear me now turn down the music
because when you turn the music down you
still hear whatever is around you in
your head so I turn the music down so
now you're just in my head yes I'm like
not reacting cuz I'm trying to process
what's happening it's the craziest thing
that's why I freaked out upstairs now
this is something else I want to show
you yeah yeah it's so weird I know I
sound loud use your everyone is in there
in your head like the volume control
that's so very very convenient
I know Cal PR you enjoying them yeah
you're ruining my spirit these are so
cool sounds really good - I know
oh these are mine now new bring back my
phones
[Music]
so they'd definitely perfect headphones
for me for editing and if you also are
like me and will binge watch an entire
season of a show and don't even think
twice about it these are also perfect
for it because you can still be immersed
into your show but also not completely
lose track of the outside world unless
you want to you just double tap this
reminds me of something from Black
Mirror like this is this is I'm what I
am living in a black mirror episode
right now like this is the future the
cell wow I can hear everything
can't hear anything beep thank you to
Dolby you guys this is incredible and I
am so excited for people to be able to
experience this I wish you wouldn't have
these before because every time like you
would watch a show I didn't watch it yet
they would be like spoilers I know I
can't hang out with you
I know here the spoilers you ever get
more information about these headphones
I will put a link in the description and
be sure to subscribe to my channel for
more videos and be sure to like this
video if you enjoyed it and that's it
I'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]